Tras el total colapso de la unión
soviética en 1991
la rusia comandada por Boris Yeltsin
parecía iniciar en un primer momento
una transición hacia lo que podemos
denominar valores occidentales, esto es,
la asunción de una economía de mercado
en el marco de instituciones
democráticas.
Sin embargo, este proceso fue un
auténtico desastre, la corrupión los
intereses de una oligarquía que cada día
se enriquecía más y más con la
liquidación del estado y, por qué no
decirlo, también, la falta de tacto y
visión de occidente al no otorgarle a
Rusia el peso merecido ni colaborar
con ella en este proceso, provocaron  una
debacle económica y social generalizada
en el gigante ruso.
- "No hay nada mejor para los traficantes de armas
que el tándem soldados descontentos y
depósitos llenos de armas". Y así,
llegamos al 31 de diciembre del 1999
momento en el que mediante un anuncio
sorpresa que emitido a las doce de la
noche
Boris Yeltsin dimitió como presidente
de Rusia y le pasó el testigo al por
aquel entonces relativamente desconocido
Vladimir Putin, un ex agente de la KGB
que llegó que una misión clara:
luchar porque la madre rusia recobrase
su estatus de gran potencia mundial.
Para lograrlo, Putin acometió un
cambio de modelo y definió un nuevo
sistema basado en: un crecimiento del
poder militar; una mayor influencia
internacional; la concentración del
poder en manos del líder; el impulso
a un destacado fervor nacionalista; y la
recuperación de valores tradicionales,
como la familia o la iglesia. Gracias al
boom del petróleo y las materias primas,
Putín contó, además, con importantísimos
recursos extras que le ayudaron a llevar a
cabo sus planes. Por ejemplo, desde el
año 2003
Rusia ha invertido la friolera de
750.000 millones de dolares
en  la modernización de
sus fuerzas armadas. Pero, dicho esto,
vamos a ver cuáles son las claves de la
política exterior rusa y la
explicación a su creciente hostilidad
con las potencias occidentales. Porque,
cómo veremos, no se trata de una
cuestión de testosterona o de ambición
de poder, sino de una estrategia de
seguridad y defensa perfectamente
definida.
Rusia no tiene fronteras naturales lo
que conduce a que su política de
seguridad y defensa esté muy
influenciada por el riesgo de invasión.
Algo que, además, está muy presente la
conciencia colectiva dada las
experiencias históricas vividas: desde la
invasión de los mongoles, ya por el
siglo XIII;  hasta la última de la Alemania nazi pasando por la invasión de
Napoleón. Para responder a ese riesgo
el planteamiento de seguridad nacional
apuesta por la creación de las llamadas
zonas buffer, o espacios de seguridad
entre Rusia y sus enemigos potenciales.
En otras palabras
Moscú considera absolutamente necesario
para su seguridad controlar a sus vecinos,
evitando de esta forma que puedan ser
hostiles a sus intereses, que se acerquen
a occidente o que adquieran de facto
plena autonomía. - "Veteranos, sois nuestro
modelo. Habéis contribuido con vuestro
ejemplo moral a devolver Crimea y
Sebastopol a su patria".
Por ello la política de seguridad
rusa contempla tres escenarios de
intervención prioritaria: por un lado el
antiguo grupo de repúblicas soviéticas
de Europa Oriental - Ucrania, Bielorrusia y
¡ojo! las repúblicas bálticas -, por otro
el Cáucaso y Asia Central y, finalmente,
por último, el Pacífico.
Pero, de forma concreta ¿qué amenazas
observa Moscú? Pues, tanto la Estrategia
de Seguridad Nacional, como el Plan de
Desarrollo Estratégico 2020 y la
Doctrina Militar en vigor, definen que
los mayores riesgos pasan, precisamente,
porque Estados Unidos y la Unión
Europea consigan cambiar el equilibrio
de poder en las mencionadas "zonas de
influencia natural" ¿cómo? Mediante la
ampliación de la OTAN y el impulso al
comercio libre y la integración
económica - "Kiev y Bruselas impulsan el
desarrollo de un nuevo acuerdo de
asociación y libre comercio, aunque las
autoridades ucranianas tendrán que
esforzarse para acometer reformas
constitucionales".
De hecho, la crisis en Ucrania se
desencadenó, precisamente, con la decisión
del presidente Yanukóvich de suspender
la firma del acuerdo asociación y libre
comercio entre Ucrania y la Unión
Europea. En 2008 la guerra con Georgia
tuvo también mucho que ver con la
intención de ese país de adherirse a
la OTAN.
Bien, los documentos en vigor también
reconocen como riesgos principales la
conversión de las ex repúblicas
soviéticas de Asia Central en estados
fallidos, lo que impediría de facto que
sirviesen de zona buffer entre Rusia y
la conflictiva zona de Oriente Medio.
De hecho, una de las situaciones de más
riesgos que Moscú contempla, es el
contagio de esta región, de mayoría
musulmana, por el islamismo radical de
los yihadistas de Siria e Irak. Las
nuevas formas de guerra como es el caso
de los ciberconflictos, también son
destacados en todos los informes.
¿cómo se enfrenta la Rusia de Putin
a todas estas amenazas? Pues os
aseguro amigos que este punto es realmente
interesante. En aras de obtener
legitimidad e incrementar su capacidad
de influencia, Putin ha convertido a las
minorías rusas de las diferentes
repúblicas ex soviéticas en un eje
central de su política exterior, y
hablamos de una diáspora de más de 25
millones de personas. En palabras de Putín: "los rusos se han convertido en la
nación más grande del mundo separada
por fronteras". De hecho, el gobierno ruso
considera la diáspora como un valioso
instrumento de política exterior. Pero,
¿cómo se materializa el uso de la
diáspora? Pues, por ejemplo, en lo que
algunos analistas denominan la
estrategia de las siete fases. Así,
cuando una de las repúblicas ex
soviéticas tiene la tentación de
acercarse a occidente o enfrentarse a
Rusia, el Kremlin pone en marcha como
medida de presión
este plan, tal y como ya vimos en Georgia
y Ucrania. Estas son las siete fases del
plan de Moscú: en la primera etapa impulsar
los lazos lingüísticos, culturales y
religiosos que sean capaces de
incrementar los vínculos de la minoría
rusa con Moscú. En segundo lugar proveer
de asistencia social a este grupo;
asistencia como comida medicamentos o
financiación e inversiones económicas.
En tercer lugar, impulsar una comunidad
completa y diferenciada, mediante la
articulación de instituciones propias y
de una estructura de representación y
movilización.
La cuarta etapa supone un paso más,
la otorgación de la ciudadanía rusa
a los miembros de la diáspora. Y, por su
parte, la quinta fase del plan se centra en
controlar la información y alimentar
con ella las diferencias existentes
entre la población local y la minoría
rusa, enfatizando, por ejemplo, casos de
discriminación. Alcanzado este punto, el
gobierno ruso ha adquirido ya una gran
capacidad de influencia y presión sobre el
gobierno local, que observa cómo las
estructuras sociales de su país se
desquebrajan y crece la conflictividad.
Ahora bien, cuando todo ello no es
suficiente, Moscú pasa en la medida de
lo posible a la sexta y séptima
etapa: la asistencia y protección a sus
compatriotas, la imposición de
sanciones económicas, políticas y
comerciales; y en última instancia la
intervención para el ejercicio del
control formal, tal y como ocurrió en
Crimea.
Se trata, en última instancia, de buscar
un claro escarmiento que disuada
cualquier futuro cambio político no
alineado con sus intereses.
- "El gasoducto está cerrado. El gas ha
dejado de fluir desde Rusia hacia
Ucrania".
Asimismo, como mecanismo preventivo Putin
ha impulsado, aunque con un pobre
resultado, la verdad, la Unión
Euroasiática, un proyecto de
integración económica y política.
Algo así, como la Unión Europea de
Rusia. De cara al resto del mundo la
apuesta de Moscú pasa por impulsar los
lazos con potencias regionales, como
China e Irán, por ejemplo y tal y como
defiende el Jefe del Estado Mayor.
Valeri Gerasimov, utilizar la guerra híbrida como elemento de defensa y poder.
¡Atentos!
Esto es, valerse para lograr sus
objetivos de instrumentos no
convencionales: escenarios de propaganda
y guerra informativa, donde por ejemplo RT
juega un papel clave. Ejercer la
guerra económica, apoyar las
inestabilidades locales o recurrir a los
ciberataques -"Hackers o piratas cibernéticos
rusos fueron los responsables de haberle
robado y filtrado los correos
electrónicos de el Comité Nacional
Demócrata". Además, no podemos olvidar
que más allá de una política de
defensa, Putin ha sustentado su
popularidad en  lo que algunos ya
denominan el regreso del Imperio Ruso
Así que, nadie se lleve a engaños, amigos la
tensión con Rusia no se terminará
pronto.
Bueno, ¿qué pensáis vosotros? ¿continuará
la creciente hostilidad con Rusia?
¿Veremos una nueva guerra fría? ¿Es
efectiva la estrategia de Putin?
Espero vuestros comentarios y si os ha
gustado el vídeo no dudéis en darle
a like y suscribiros al canal. Un saludo y
hasta la próxima.